Is it really Westeros without dragons and kings?
The upcoming Game of Thrones spinoff The Hedge
Knight might just give viewers an entirely
new perspective on life in the Seven Kingdoms.
"I could tell you about Ser Duncan the
Tall. Those were always your favorites."
Game of Thrones had its fair share of really,
really tall characters. There's the Hound,
who in the books is said to measure in at 6 feet
8 inches. The actor who played him, Rory McCann,
is a close 6 feet, 6 inches. Then there was his
brother, the Mountain, who was played by multiple
actors, but most notably by Icelandic strongman
Hafþór Björnsson, who is 6 feet 9 inches. While
certainly above average for a man, the book's
iteration of the Mountain was even taller.
Then, there was Brienne of Tarth, portrayed
by the 6-foot-3-inch Gwendoline Christie.
Martin describes her as about 6 and a
half feet. And who could forget Hodor,
the gentle giant brought to life by 6-foot-10-inch
actor Kristian Nairn, who held the door for Bran.
The Hedge Knight will introduce another
person of preposterous stature to the Game
of Thrones extended universe. The protagonist
and point-of-view character, Dunk, is so tall
that instead of his family or place of birth,
his defining characteristic becomes his name.
Ser Duncan the Tall is reported to be nearly 7
feet by one account and exactly 6 feet, 11 inches
by another. His size isn't just remarkable enough
to have been preserved in Westeros' history books;
it's also a comedic contrast between Dunk and
his traveling companion, the diminutive Egg.
Very few actors match Dunk's stats, and
productions usually use camera trickery and
digital effects to create such illusions. Among
the fans' suggestions for Dunk are Henry Cavill
and George MacKay. Both standing in the vicinity
of 6 feet in height, they're tall for movie stars,
but not for knights. Since Ser Duncan's appearance
is so important to the story, many readers are
hoping for a properly towering figure, which
might mean casting someone relatively unknown.
Of all Martin's books, A Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms should be the easiest to adapt. Game
of Thrones had to fit thousands of pages
of story into Seasons 1-5, while House of
the Dragon uses only a tiny section of
Fire & Blood for its first 10 episodes.
Both had to contend with dozens of locations
and hundreds of characters. The Hedge Knight
and its accompanying graphic novel, on
the other hand, are less than 200 pages
and feature one main setting and a manageable
number of central players. This means that,
assuming the showrunners keep the book to a
single season, the show ought to be able to
render the events of the novella at about the
same pace and with the same amount of detail.
But adaptations shouldn't be afraid
to make changes that improve the
story for the new medium. One area
where the TV show could do better
than the book is in its depiction of
Dunk's mentor, Ser Arlan of Pennytree.
Arlan is an archetypical Game of
Thrones character: like Davos Seaworth,
he's an older nobleman and hardworking knight
with a grizzled appearance and demeanor,
good intentions, and a slightly
mysterious backstory. Unfortunately,
we never actually meet him in Martin's
writing, and some fans want the series to
correct that. While some folks on Reddit
have suggested starting the show with
Ser Arlan, others think Ser Arlan and Dunk's
relationship could be handled in flashbacks.
Family words and crests play a vital
part in the overall aesthetic and the
narrative of Game of Thrones. There
are also many ancestral weapons like
swords and shields that mean a
great deal to various characters.
"See that sword? It's called Heartsbane."
Ser Duncan's shield serves as the cover of some
editions of A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms, and
it's a major Easter egg that supposedly connects
Dunk to a beloved major character down the line,
though fans have yet to discover exactly how.
In all likelihood, viewers of The Hedge Knight
will get to see the origin story behind
that shield and its design early in Season
1. The ultimate reveal, however, probably
won't come until closer to the show's end.
When Dunk comes into possession
of Ser Arlan's belongings,
he realizes that since he isn't Arlan's
son, he cannot use the Pennytree's symbol
or colors — a winged silver chalice against
a brown backdrop. The problem is that Dunk
isn't anybody's son. He was orphaned in his
infancy and knows nothing about his heritage.
To become a respected-enough hedge knight to enter
tournaments and find work, he basically has to
invent an identity for himself. How plausible
that identity is, both to Dunk and to noble
outside observers, is one of the main catalysts
of the action in A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
The way in which Dunk comes by his
new personal coat of arms is one
of the book's more captivating subplots.
The image — an elm tree under a shooting
star — is quite beautiful and sure
to adorn tons of official merch.
Besides dragons, palace intrigue, violence,
and frozen zombies, Game of Thrones is also
known for its steamy romances. A cursory
glance through the history of Westeros
relationships will reveal that most of them are
complicated, if not utterly doomed from the start.
If The Hedge Knight hews closely to the text at
all, Dunk will have his very own fraught subplot
with a love interest, and it's one that some fans
of the novella are deeply invested in. When he
arrives at the tournament at Ashford, Ser Duncan
makes the acquaintance of Tanselle, a Dornish
artist and puppeteer who goes from town to town
with her uncle as part of a troupe of performers.
Dunk can't get the statuesque Tanselle —
whose nickname is Too-Tall — out of his mind.
Even those who haven't read the book can probably
guess how things go for Dunk and Tanselle,
based only on the premise that they both
lead somewhat transient lifestyles and
Martin's tendency to rip lovers apart
as soon as he gets them together.
The fates of iconic couples like Daenerys
and Drogo, Robb Stark and Talisa, Jon Snow
and Ygritte, Jaime Lannister and Brienne,
Missandei and Grey Worm, and Jon Snow and
Daenerys still pull at the heartstrings
of many viewers. But that's not the point.
The point is, Martin's best pairings crackle with
tension, particularly before they get together.
Dunk doesn't have Tyrion's wit or Jaime's charm,
but he's as much a lover as he is a fighter,
and The Hedge Knight should let his chivalrous
lead fall hard enough for Tanselle that he
has something to think about as he
wanders Westeros in later seasons.
There's a ancient saying
about the Targaryen dynasty:
"They say every time a Targaryen is born, the
gods toss a coin and the world holds its breath."
The two sides of this allegorical coin
are greatness and madness. Dunk and
audiences will come into contact with
a whole new generation of Targaryens in
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms, and
that coin flip wisdom will hold up.
At court around the time of Ser Duncan are
Prince Maekar and Prince Baelor Breakspear,
as well as Maekar's sons, the Princes Daeron,
Aerion, Aemon, and Aegon. Daeron goes down in
history as Daeron the Drunken. He's plagued by
prophetic dreams and self-medicates with drink
and women to ease his mind. He's no peach,
but his fellow prince Aerion is much worse.
Aerion, who calls himself Brightflame, will
probably function as the main antagonist
in The Hedge Knight. As Targaryens go, he
doesn't inflict the worst or the most damage,
though he's still completely vile and cruel.
He's in the running for most mad, however.
This vicious prince is really into
his family's history with dragons — so
much so that he eventually believes
himself to be one. Aerion decorates
his clothing to approximate the look
of a dragon and dabbles in dark magic.
To compare his character
to another fantasy series,
he's like a combination of Gilderoy
Lockhart crossed with Voldemort from
Harry Potter. He's the antithesis of
Dunk, who's kind and self-deprecating.
If HBO Max's The Hedge Knight gets their
rivalry right, the series should be a hit.
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms takes place
almost exactly in between House of the Dragon,
and Game of Thrones. Dragons existed during
those series, but sadly, they're extinct in
Dunk and Egg's age. Will casual viewers still
tune in for a dragon-less fantasy show? Some
fans don't think it'll be a problem thanks
to another massive spectacle — tournaments!
While duels and jousting might not sound
especially enticing to fans used to
seeing enormous monsters on screen, without CGI
dragons taking a bite out of production budgets,
that money can go toward making
Season 1's tournaments extra grand.
Of course, there have been several tournaments
in series set in Westeros already. On Game
of Thrones, Robert, Joffrey, and Renly
Baratheon all hold tourneys. For its part,
House of the Dragon's premier episode
showcases Viserys Targaryen's tournament
intended to celebrate the birth
of his and Aemma's son with one.
Since several prominent tales in A Knight of
the Seven Kingdoms take place at tourneys,
this should mean they'll take center stage in
the television adaptation. If done correctly,
instead of montages of jousting and swordplay,
The Hedge Knight ought to show the tourney in
full and allow the audience to get
to know and care about each entrant.
Westeros isn't exactly an egalitarian society.
There's a ruling class and a working class,
and they're unmistakably distinct
from each other. Though being of
noble birth comes with its challenges, it's
no picnic being a servant at King's Landing,
let alone a peasant on the streets of Flea Bottom.
One of the few contexts in which the landed
gentry and the common folk mix? Live theater!
Mummers troupes often perform lewd versions
of royal history in the world of Thrones for
the rich and the poor alike. For example, Teenage
Rhaenyra gets a taste of local politics when her
uncle Daemon takes her on a late-night field
trip to witness a roast of her own family.
As previously mentioned, Tanselle is a member of a
troupe of puppeteers that's assembled to entertain
the crowds gathered for the tourney. That troupe
puts on what turns out to be quite a controversial
and consequential show with marionette-like wooden
dragons. While it upsets characters in-world,
the show's potential audience in our world
should get excited to see them acted out.
The creators of Game of Thrones and House of the
Dragon have done an exemplary job already with
these types of stories within stories. Tanselle's
puppet show is yet another chance for the
cast and crew of The Hedge Knight to get creative
putting their own spin on a franchise tradition.
Just as the citizens of Westeros
don't enjoy income equality,
they also can't depend on a very fair
legal system. For those suspected of
a crime in Martin's world, the choice is often
between corporal punishment or trial by combat.
"I demand a Trial by Combat."
Game of Thrones fans have been present
for some marquee trials by combat,
mostly involving Tyrion Lannister. Bronn
fights on his behalf the first time,
Oberyn Martell the second. These scenes are
some of the highlights of the whole series.
Without giving too much away, Dunk finds himself
in a similar position at some point during
the events of A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
Fortunately, he's more than capable of defending
himself. Unfortunately, his adversary demands
a Trial by Seven, in which both the accuser
and the accused must assemble a team of seven
to square off in what amounts to a mega-duel.
This is easier said than done for Dunk, who
isn't highborn and doesn't have a Lannister's
money or connections. The Trial by Seven is
the climax of The Hedge Knight and fans on
Twitter are losing their minds about the
possibility of seeing it in live action.
It will be the first time book readers
will see a Trial by Seven on screen,
with each knight battling with his
choice of fighting style and weapon,
and it will put a number of the show's main
characters in a life-or-death situation.
If all goes well, The Hedge Knight could comprise
the first of at least three seasons
of A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
While there are some recognizable tie-ins to
the author's overarching story in part one,
most of the stuff fans are really waiting to see
won't happen until much later in Dunk's life.
Ser Duncan plays a pivotal role in the
Blackfyre Rebellions. He's rumored to
have fathered at least one child and is
thought to be related to at least one
fan-favorite Game of Thrones character.
He even crosses paths with the likes of
A Song of Ice and Fire veterans Walder
Frey, Barristan Selmy, and Maester Aemon.
Though Dunk's tale is relatively modest in scope
and length, it offers a fresh perspective into key
pieces of Martin's lore. Not to mention, Ser
Duncan the Tall becomes a legendary knight in
his own regard. We don't know if A Knight of the
Seven Kingdoms will stop where the novellas do as
of now or if Martin and Max will explore Westeros
through Dunk's eyes beyond "The Mystery Knight."
But we can hope that if "The Hedge Knight" is
successful, this series and other spin offs could
eventually give fans live-action adaptations
of more of their favorite book moments.